daddy's home all right the boys season
two is out let's
binge it i know huh three episodes
well that is kind of a dick move wish to
be fair i do understand why we have
three episodes i don't understand why we
don't have all the episodes of season
two out
it's like they were like all right in
this world where movies aren't coming
out week to week we're gonna have
episodes of a series come out week to
week yeah it's called network television
we're going backwards the beauty of
video on demand is being lost
let's not go backwards come on so that's
stupid but in a world where we're not
going to get all the episodes of season
two i understand why we have
at least three because it takes three to
really kind of see where the series is
going but that's how the boys
is set up like every episode of the boys
is one eighth
of an eight hour episode essentially so
i appreciate that they recognized
you need three episodes in order for
fans to not be like what the [ __ ] am i
here because this is what it would be
like episode 1 i'd be like
i'm glad billy butcher came back by the
end
i love him i love that guy it dawns on
me i don't
think i'm supposed to see billy butcher
as a hero
but i do so i'd be like okay i'm glad
homelander had a good intro i'm glad
billy butcher's back that scene with
homelander where they have this new guy
and he's like hmm
what if i do this pow oh god it's so
dark
in episode two i'd be like stormfront
annoys me she she does if they left me
week to week for the entire week after
i saw stormfront i'd be like that's what
i'd be thinking i'd be like she's
annoying she has that like condescend
you know what
she's from portland i don't mean to
offend
oh my portland fans i'm just you gotta
admit that said
portland i do love your kale but by
episode three you see you're like oh
that's where they're going with
stormfront that could be a very
compelling arc and there's homelander
who keeps
he's essentially just invading the home
of
butcher's wife and it's just like oh hey
i'm going to hang out here and help
raise your kid and it's an
uncomfortable as hell situation
absolutely but it does get me thinking
let's let's get the [ __ ] out of here so
homeland is just like all right i don't
train my son
and so this the kid realizes he does
have power in which the mom was like no
i'm just not going to tell him about it
because it'll make his life easier in
this super
isolated super jurassic park prison so i
understand that
now that the door's been opened the
genie's been let out of the bottle
you might as well train him a bit when
homelander does
go back to hang out with the seven let's
get you super strong
and help you fly so you can pick me up
and we can both
fly the [ __ ] out of here to coco mode
that's where we want to go
way down to kokomo so everything that
started out
in the first couple episodes and say
well i hope they go somewhere
interesting with this
it actually looks like it's going
interesting places by the end of episode
three
so again i see why they gave us three
episodes which also speaks to the fact
that i also see
why the boyz is supposed to be a binge
i understand if anybody here is like i'm
just gonna wait till it comes out
because i love the binge
i love the bench but you know i'm a
youtube person and i
kind of plot out the week of videos and
this was on the schedule it really threw
a [ __ ] wrench in it depending on how
anyone
sees this video or gives a [ __ ] maybe
i'll do the episodes week to week maybe
i'll do one
video at the end when it's all over and
we'll just talk about the season as a
whole maybe i'll do one episode week to
week and then do a wrap
up talking about the season as a whole i
don't know we'll see how it goes i don't
plan that far ahead so after three
episodes i can say i'm looking forward
to where the season's going it does show
that there's
there's a difference between vots and
the seven which the whistle is blown now
the world knows about compound v's
there's gonna be a lot of damage control
it's gonna be
the seven is gonna be like maybe we
maybe just leave
them behind or maybe we'll help them get
out of this [ __ ] i don't know but i do
appreciate it when a show does move
something forward because the whole
thing was like ooh compound v we got to
get it out there and they did and that's
this season now and as much as our crew
as much as the boys they argue that
bicker they fight
they are a weird dysfunctional family so
looking forward to it
i really want to binge it though what a
dick move i'm just
saying why not whatever right so the
boys season two have you seen it what
did you think about it no you haven't
the first three episodes of season two
have you seen it why did you think about
it whatever you thought comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you